let's talk about business regulations
last year the US EPA started the process
of banning a really really toxic
pesticide called chlorpyrifos
chlorpyrifos I'm not exactly sure how
it's pronounced for years health experts
and scientists and environmentalist they
were trying to get this chemical banned
there's zero question about it being
unhealthy for humans the national
pesticide information center says that
inhalation causes tearing of the eyes
runny-nosed increased saliva and sweat
production nausea dizziness headache
muscle twitching weakness or abdominal
pain tremors lack of coordination
vomiting diarrhea pupil constriction
with blurred and darkened vision this is
pretty serious stuff and that children
who are exposed to chlorpyrifos can be
can end up with lowered IQ and higher
rates of autism in March Donald Trump's
EPA run of course by Scott Pruett does
what they stopped the process of banning
this chemical chemical they change their
stance and they ultimately approve this
chemical outrage in a wide variety of
health advocacy agency and agencies
environmental advocacy agencies one of
the first major decisions made by
Trump's EPA Administrator is to stop the
process of banning a chemical known to
be really bad for human health Dow
Chemical not surprisingly love the
decision here is a quote from Dow
Chemical where they said Dow
AgroSciences remains confident that
authorized uses of chlorpyrifos products
offer wide margins of protection for
human health and safety unrelated I'm
sure
Dow Chemical donated a million dollars
to Donald Trump's inaugural committee
unrelated I'm sure merely a coincidence
Dow Chemical chairman and CEO Andrew
Liveris goes to Donald Trump rallies and
Trump appointed him as chair of the
administration's American manufacturing
Council mere coincidences right so what
happened on May 5th about a month after
this thing was that the banning process
was stopped six weeks maybe a farm just
outside Bakersfield California seized
over fifty farm workers
reportedly exposed to an airborne
chemical that caused strange symptoms
twelve of them reported vomiting one of
them lost consciousness it was later
discovered that these workers were
poisoned by none other than chlorpyrifos
that had drifted through the air from
another farm the Kern County Public
Health media officer addressed the
public on TV saying quote anybody that
was exposed that was here today we
encourage them to seek medical attention
immediately
don't wait particularly if you're
suffering from any symptoms whether it's
nausea vomiting diarrhea seek medical
attention immediately
Dow Chemical had manufactured it and
they did not respond to phone calls or
emails about the incident if only we had
an agency that dealt with this sort of
thing oh wait a second we've got the EPA
except the EPA decided to go against
scientific consensus and approve this
chemical Trump's been in office for a
few months now I alluded to this the
other day when we were talking about the
Dakota access pipeline oil spill we're
starting to get to the point in Trump's
presidency where it isn't just executive
orders with no direct impact the things
Trump and his cronies are doing are
actually happening in the real world and
impacting and hurting people and it's
not like when Republicans went to the
polls in November that they were
demanding a reverse on the ban of this
chemical I mean yeah maybe they wanted
lower taxes smaller government draining
the swamp but it seems like when you get
Republicans in there you get all these
extracurricular activities that no one
really wants and don't mistake this for
some kind of virtuous free market
libertarian idealism right I mean it
that's not what's regulating this dreg
it's not what's guiding this
deregulation and the negligence this is
patronage to corporations I told about
the donations from Dow and the the
connections between Dow Chemical CEO and
Donald Trump this is the exact type of
crony capitalist swamp filling that
Donald Trump promised he would end and
it's not ending it's actually
accelerating I would argue right I mean
most of the time libertarianism it just
kind of translates to pro corporatism
right and you know but I think even
people who are in favor of small
government realized that the government
should
be in charge of basic protection for our
health and I think this certainly
qualifies even to them
fringe libertarians might disagree with
you but more reasonable libertarians I
think get that you need some degree
something something in terms of
regulating business